mark McCloskey joins us tonight mark
thanks so much for coming on so before I
ask you about how you feel about this
reimagine public safety you've been
subjected to tell us tell us
specifically what happened when the
police visited your home recently well
you know the the police were really very
professional very nice the the cops had
came out to issue the search warrant on
us
they're almost apologetic they they
didn't want to have to be there they're
doing their job
I mean Patti wanted to take a picture to
document it and she asked them if they
wouldn't mind facing away from the
camera so that people wouldn't get mad
at them if their faces were shown on TV
and they were all they all did so I mean
they they unfortunately are stuck
between a circuit attorney that wants to
prosecute us and their own belief that
we did absolutely nothing wrong
it goes that saying I mean police
departments are structured along the
lines the military they don't make
independent decisions they're told what
to do when they do it so they didn't
make this decision independently but you
still can't escape the contrast between
what happened the night the mob came to
your home you call the police they
didn't come and then they come at the
command of the prosecuting attorney
later to take the firearm you used to
defend yourself I mean what is that what
police are for do you think well you
know and this is the same I my attorney
advised me not to be on the show tonight
because the rumor is that we're going to
be indicted shortly okay
having said that this is the same
circuit attorney there at least a 35 of
the protesters a torched and looted
downtown st. Louis but now she wants to
indict me I didn't shoot anybody I just
held my ground protected my house and
I'm sitting here on television tonight
instead of dead or putting up the
smoldering embers of my home so I mean I
your strategy in response to all this
seems to be staying silent doesn't get
you anything obviously if you just
retreated into your house it probably
would be burned to the ground as you as
you just said but is that how society
should function I mean shouldn't someone
in authority in the state of Missouri be
coming to your aid right about now
you know I the way I view it is that
when you have certain elements of
society encouraging violence
at the same time asking the police to
stand down what's the only possible
result the only possible solution is for
individual citizen is to stand up and
defend themselves and I'm afraid that
what's being promoted is causing
citizens to stand up and defend
themselves so they can be like chilled
and and and and you know abused the way
we have been I don't think there's any
doubt about that I don't think there's a
homeowner in America who wants to defend
his home his own home with a gun I mean
that's something you do if you have no
choice you'd much rather the police came
and took the risk for you that's why you
pay them but they but they won't what do
you make of the media response you were
lectured on another channel by a guy
who's repeatedly threatened violence
against people actually threatened
violence against people for getting in
his space and yet he dressed you down
for defending your home what do you make
of that well you know the the
traditional media is right behind the
the mob I mean we're not allowed to use
that word anymore the the large crowd of
angry people and are supporting these
entities which are from my understanding
Marxist and opposed everything that I
stand for and I hold dear and they're
and we've gotten tremendous support from
ordinary people my my phones and mic my
emails are running about 90% positive
now we've gotten calls from all over the
world I got a nice letter from a lady in
Ireland this morning congratulating us
for taking a stand against the violence
and so I think the vast majority of
Americans wish they could do something
the problem is that if nobody stands up
and supports them if the media blasts
them if they I'm self-employed I mean I
don't own long law firm but what if I
was an employee somewhere if I did what
I did and I was an employee of anybody
else I'd have been can the next day my
family would have been can no one would
ever get a job again this is the kind of
social pressure that keeps people from
standing up and defending themselves
right I think it's time for people to
take a different stand to actually stand
up and have some risk I mean Patrick
Henry said give me liberty or give me
death now everybody's afraid of losing
their job I think you're exactly right
slogans like that are meaningless unless
people in power stand up to defend to
defend the country Markovski who's
defended himself we appreciate her
coming on tonight despite lawyers
counsel thank you
Thank You Tucker